one day after actress Holland Taylor
revealed she's dating a woman a source
confirms the et that woman is actress
Sarah paulsen it matters not at all who
what the gender of the person is it's
very clear that love is love a source
tells ET sarah and holland have been
dating for a few months and according to
their adorably affectionate tweets
they've been hanging out since at least
January
earlier this month Holland posted this
photo of Poulsen in a gorgeous gown
writing when captions fail and on
November 19th she returned the affection
writing you are so beautiful
period the end Colin got candid about
her sexuality in a recent radio
interview with WNYC saying quote most of
my relationships have been with women
and while the 72 year old wouldn't
reveal her girlfriend's identity she did
reveal there's a very big age difference
between them Holland is 32 years older
than Sarah Polson but she's no stranger
to dating with an age gap the 40 year
old American Horror Story actress
previously dated 59 year old actress
cherry Jones